thank you um
welcome to the area the central area
planning committee on the 17th of
november
2021
um my name is councillor jeannette
stilts and i am the chairman of this
committee
before we commence the business of this
meeting there's a few housekeeping rules
to run through members the setup for the
meeting has been designed to mitigate
the covid therefore can i ask all
present to work to the protocol agreed
full council on 29th of april 2021 in
the interest of member and officer
safety we are streaming this meeting
live as well as the recording and by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up or raise your
just put your hand up to indicate you
wish to speak is right we got rid of the
paddles i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
when the invite when you invite you to
speak please remove your mask
turn on your microphone and speak
clearly please please reference page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit door is
behind the top table
item two on the agenda apologies for
absence tara do we have apologies for
absence uh yes chairman thank you
apologies have been received from
councillor edwards councillor mays and
councillor shawnee thank you chairman
thank you
item three on the agenda
um it is recommended that minutes of the
meeting held on the
20th of october thank you found on pages
7 to 14 are approved as a true and
accurate record i so do
move
have i a seconder for that motion
counselor heard thank you
our members in agreement with that
lovely thank you
item three on the four on the agenda
declaration of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
kinder interest other peculiar interests
or non-pecuniary interests related to
items of business on the agenda have in
regards to paragraph six to a inclusive
of code
of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting do i
have any declarations of interest
counselor bill thank you chairman i
actually did a litter pick the other
tuesday with the general manager
and i did talk to him about it
thank you but that's that's about it
thank you cancerfield
councillor lagan
yeah just for correctness i'd just
declare non-pecuniary that many many
many moons ago i have visited the
restaurant
thank you thank you councillor
any other declarations of interest
no
item five we move to the agenda item
fight found on pages
so i'm trying to 15
thank you found on pages 15 22.
um
officer if you would like to introduce
yourself and present your report please
thank you chairman i'm hannah dungay
specialist in development management
advertisement consent is thought for the
installation of five single-faced
digital freestanding signs to serve the
two-lane drive through recently approved
by committee on 28th of july at the
existing mcdonald's in full bridge as
well as one digital booth screen which
would be attached to the eastern
elevation of the building
this application follows a previously
refused application at this committee on
the 28th of july for four double and one
single face digital freestanding sign
this application therefore is a revision
to that refuse scheme by a reduction in
the scale of the development proposed
this is the site location plan for the
application
this is an aerial photograph of the site
as you can see the site is located
within an existing commercial area where
there are a number of businesses
businesses located in close proximity to
the site
there are no residential properties
within close proximity to the
site this is the existing block plan of
the site which shows the outline of the
current single lane arrangement at the
drive through of the site which is over
here
and this is the block plan of the site
recently approved by virtue of
application reference twenty one forward
slash zero zero two six nine forward
slash ful
which shows the location of the proposed
signage in relation to the new drive
through lanes at the site
as you can see from the red and green
boxes the signs outlined in red are the
single face digital freestanding signs
serving the drive through
and the sign outlined in green is the
digital booth screen
on the eastern elevation of the building
for comparison this is the block plan of
the previously refused application
although the location of the proposed
signs are similar to the current
application
four of the previous
digital freestanding signs which were
double screens have now been removed
from the proposal and replaced with
single screens only so all five signs
are now single width and single sided
these are the elevations of the signage
that was proposed as part of the
previous application and have now been
replaced as part of the
current scheme
these are the elevations of the signs
proposed as part of the current scheme
and as you can see these are single
digital screens only
and these are the elevations of the
digital booth screen
proposed to be attached to the eastern
elevation of the existing building and
that sign measures 15 inches
in width
these are photographs showing the
existing um mcdonald's at the site and
as you can see from
these three photographs here here and
here
um taken from the a414
this the area where the proposed
drive-through is located would not be
widely visible within the surrounding
area
um and this full photograph here is
taken from tesco car park
and these are photographs of mcdonald's
within the existing context of the site
so in line with the assessment carried
out within the committee report the
reduction in the size of the digital
screens at the site from four double
width screens and one single width
screen to five single width screens only
is considered to overcome the previous
reason for refusal
and would reduce the overall visual
clutter at the site
the proposed signage would not have a
harmful impact on the character and
appearance of the area and it is
considered to be acceptable in this
locality
the proposed signage would not have a
detrimental impact on highway safety as
well
the application is therefore recommended
for approval subject to appropriate
conditions thank you chairman thank you
members is there any questions
for the
council sign
yes thank you tim thank you
and
firstly reducing from two screens to one
the actual um message on the screen is
the same size presumably as it was on
the
two double screens
as far as i'm aware it would be menu
serving the drive three yeah so just so
it was a bit excessive before then not
necessarily so and the other thing is
these are lit aren't they presumably
they're only lit during the hours that
mcdonald's were operating which is i
don't know is that 24 hours anyway
yeah i'm not sure but they wouldn't be
lit when they're not all presumed um
through you chairman i don't think we
have that information to hand or would
be able to condition that as part of the
application
as normally illuminated signs could be
illuminated could that should that be a
condition
um if you propose it
as a condition and it's seconded then
it's something that i will defer to mr
johnson that you can put as a condition
yes
not accumulation when the
premises is
not operated yes not not when the
parents are not operating so you would
have to propose that condition that
condition has to be seconded well
okay
councillor can you turn your mic off
please
cancel a hug
thank you chairman yes i'm i'm pleased
to see the reductions of the
visual clutter um i think that it's a
it's a valid point uh there's no point
in them being on to show what they've
got to to serve if they can't serve it
so i would certainly um
second councillor swain's
uh proposal to uh during the hours of
business uh that they should be
illuminated and not
uh when they're closed i i'm pretty sure
that it is 24 hours sometimes anyway so
i don't i don't have an issue with that
but when they do close it's not an area
that i would say is of any architectural
merit
but i do think it's necessary for them
to show what they've got to sell when
they're open so i'm very happy to second
councillor swain's proposal thank you
do i have any other
comments any other questions councillor
lagan then councillor bill councillor
thank you just uh just a comment really
thank you very much for the report i
don't think i could have read five to
four to three to two
as elegant as you did piano um there's
no um objections from highway safety
with more light pollution or anything
like that
do you german no there isn't anything i
know that in the report and i think that
to echo councillor heard and other
members i think
is what it is um and it does make it
visually uh more attractive on the eye
so thank you for presenting it and
making it very very clear thank you
council bill
chairman i think you'll find that in the
original application when this place was
built
um the loop that they're talking about
now was actually included in it they
just didn't go ahead with that part of
the plan so
you know they've already got permission
for it
i i've actually just been told that
mcdonald's is 24 hour
it's just
but
so members is there any other questions
for the officer
i
don't have any
recommendations to put
counselor heard
thank you chairman i propose we accept
the officer's recommendation with
conditions
the council is one yes with the
conditions yes
yes
yeah okay
okay you're going to have second that so
we need to vote on councillor swain's
condition
so that was put by councillor swain that
the condition goes in that if mcdonald's
is not operating their illuminated signs
are switched off
that was seconded by councillor heard
all those in favor of that condition
that's carried
and then the condition
the recommendation is to
accept the officer's recommendation and
to grant advertising consent and that
was proposed by councillor heard and
seconded by councillor bill
all those in favor
this one thank you
thank you
item six on the agenda is any other
items of business that chairman decides
are urgent there are none
um so therefore item seven on the me
or the agenda is closure of the meeting
members thank you for your contributions
this
uh
evening i now join the meeting to a
close
at
1942 as the meeting is now closed
members are advised
you